julia bock und agp zum rollenden studio
ein paar kameras ein mischpult und zwei
mikros reichen aus lula erreicht mit
seinen auto tunes rund eine halbe
million abonnenten bei youtube dabei lud
der dj anfangs seine clips nur für seine
folgerung ich glaube nicht dass man das
planen kann ich glaub ich habe es
versucht und die sachen die ich als hits
empfunden habt da ist nichts draus
geworden und dann lade ich so ein scheiß
hoch totaler krempel und es bekommt dann
manchmal millionen auf 10 millionen
klicks kann ich selber nicht kann keiner
eigentlich irgendwie vorhersagen ist
unmöglich
vor zwei jahren zog lula aus dem
fränkischen erlangen nach los angeles
hier produziert der 32-jährige songs und
videos mittlerweile kann er von seinen
werbeeinnahmen leben zu seinem
durchbruch verholfen hat ihm auf ein
prominenter deutscher sportler
der basketball star hat sich für einen
clip sogar in einen kleinwagen gezwängt
ich habe immer den weg als vorbild
genommen weil es einfach sich selbst und
sehr eigenartig und ich versuche genau
auch so zu sein also in dem moment wo
ich so machen was andere machen das
klappt eigentlich auch nicht also
versuche ich mache ich bin so viele wie
möglich lulas fans kommen vor allem aus
den usa kanada und australien
sein deutscher akzent scheint sie dabei
nicht zu stören im gegenteil seine
deutschkurse auf youtube ein klassiker
ein alleinstellungsmerkmal das ist
wichtig für den erfolg auf youtube das
meint gruber lang ja von der howard
universität in washington dc es ist nur
ein mausklick für sich langweilt geht
auf youtube aber wie schafft man es dass
die leute regelmäßig auf einem youtube
kanal gehen
nur indem man etwas außergewöhnliches
macht etwas überraschendes erst dann
beginnen die leute darüber nachzudenken
es gibt noch mehr ausländische youtube
stars auch die russin olga erreicht ein
amerikanisches millionenpublikum
die meisten abonnenten weltweit hat
polizei ein schwede
wenn man einen akzent hat der fremd es
dann wollen die amerikaner herausfinden
ob man etwas neues etwas ungewöhnliches
zu bieten hat etwas was sie nicht kennen
kriegen sie hier etwas geboten was sie
noch nie zuvor gesehen haben
das macht sie neugierig und weckt ihr
interesse auch außerhalb von youtube ist
lula inzwischen bekannt mit seinem
eigenwilligen wortwitz erreichte er
mittlerweile auch das fernseh publikum
und spielt kleinere rollen in filmen
bietet ihm dafür die perfekte plattform
alles läuft ein bisschen schneller hier
und locker ich glaube die sachen des
versuches denke und ich glaube das ist
nicht unbedingt was amerikanisches ich
glaube das ist was die leute wollen
einfach schnell was zusammenbasteln mal
sehen was da rauskommt keinen druck
malek hat nicht funktioniert okay was
neues was neues und das gefällt mir
flu erlebt seinen kalifornischen traum
so lange bis er sich selbst nicht mehr
sehen kann